we are so excited we just found out that
our favorite childhood law has been
transformed into ice cream so we're here
today to try it we're ready bring it on
so this is peppermint Chris and as soon
as always put in the bowl I can smell it
and it smells like childhood I'm really
going to enjoy this because I like
peppermint and I like Chris and I like
chocolate and I like ice cream yeah yeah
I feel this that is so good
cold toothpaste yeah my grandma will go
apeshit for this they totally pull this
off yeah this is just like crazy
delicious so this is Milo which is like
our version of a Nesquik it's kind of a
flavor you don't ever forget oh
definitely get a strong Milo flavor but
it doesn't have that texture that you
have when you add Milo onto ice cream
which I think I kind of miss to be
honest this doesn't really taste like
Milo to me this just tastes like
chocolate ice cream I would eat this but
I would put Milo on top still yeah why
can't we just buy ice cream put some
Milo on it mix it around and you know
save about 5 bucks it's fine
fantails own iconic Australian lollies
so I'm really excited for this there's
no quiz or anything about strong
celebrities that's a missed opportunity
that would have been fun this is one of
the ones that you can't really fake at
home so I'm pretty excited they've done
it for us I feel like if a caramello
koala was ice cream it would be very
much so like this no this is better than
a caramello koala ice cream tastes like
they got their hands on the gate I'm ice
cream that probably didn't so great and
they were like what do we do with this
they definitely pull this one off
I just love Smarties acting they're so
much better than M&Ms I'm really not
expecting much so I'm probably expecting
chocolate ice cream with some chunks of
smartie in it which is just chocolate
tastes like chocolate ice cream or smart
either
you can easily just do this on the cheap
with cheap ice cream and real Smarties
to be honest I'd rather just have an M&M
McFlurry because M&Ms are better fruit
tingles are just an iconic part of your
childhood so to have that in ice cream
form is just like a nostalgia kit this
is not something that I feel you can
really do at home this just tastes like
straight happiness it's like the ice
cream version of those bananas yellow is
definitely the worst fruit tingle flavor
and that's what I'm getting into
I'm not into it IRA schooled me this one
they could have maybe tried a bit harder
to make the ice cream taste like a fruit
jingle like actually taking for it
tingles and like turned that into ice
cream not just having fruit tingles
diets yeah like more really fruit
tingles weren't made to be turned into
an ice cream that's a bad idea
after today I really feel like I got
reminded with a lot of childhood flavors
but I kind of feel like I was taking
down that road in a cheats way some of
them work some didn't it's okay but I
feel like you can just do a cheap
version at home